hi
i'm shu yankow i'm a scientist from
amazon alexa ai team
today my teammate chenwei and i will be
presenting our demo paper for alexa
conversations we will also show you how
you can build a task oriented dialog
system from scratch using our alexa
conversation platform
alexa open night out
welcome to night out a beta skill
searches
what are the show times in san francisco
here is what i found in san francisco
today
impractical joker alexa the movie what
are the show times for emma
here are the show times for emma
can you show me the showtime after
9 p.m
here are the show times for emma after
9pm
what are the show times for sony the
hedgehog
here are the show times for sonic the
hedgehog
how long is it
sonic the hedgehog runs for one hour and
39 minutes
what is its rating
sonic the hedgehog has a rating of 6.5
on imdb based on 100 000 votes
can you get me two adult tickets for 9
45 pm show
okay
you can purchase two adult tickets for
the 9 45 pm show at centuries
cisco center
actually can you change it to two adult
tickets and three child tickets
okay
you can purchase two adults and three
child tickets for the 9 45 pm show at
century san francisco center 9 and xd
from atom tickets for 67 us dollars and
45 cents including tax
would you like to purchase the tickets
using amazon pay
no thanks bye
now let's see how our system works at
the wrong time when the user says what
are the show times in san francisco our
system will execute a sequence of
actions
as you can see the system will first
make an api called find movies with cd
argument as san francisco
this api is to fetch all the movie show
times even some location time or movie
name constraint
this api call will then return a result
set m1 that contain possible movie show
times for san francisco note that m1 is
a compound object dictionary that may
contain several movie names and its
correspondingly show times
after that the system will execute
another action which will invoke a
natural language template involved movie
this action actually generates a
response based on the template name and
its associated argument value result
then the system will execute wait for
next user input action to end this turn
the similar logic is applied to the next
turn and so on so forth
so to summarize the runtime at each turn
our conversational system will execute a
sequence of actions which can be either
api or energy or wait for next user
input action all the actions are defined
by action name followed by its
associated arguments at each turn we
predict and execute
one action at a time until wait for next
user input action is executed also at
each turn our machine learning based
model directly predicts the next action
to execute given the entire dialog
history no rule based policy is involved
in this prediction process also there is
no dialogue state tracking model
we use three different models to predict
the next action to execute
an action prediction model to predict
the name of the next action an argument
feeling model to fill the arguments
given the predictive action name finally
we also have a named entity recognition
model to tag the entities for each user
audience the ner model did not directly
contribute to the prediction of the next
action but rather help the other two
models to do more accurate prediction so
let's talk about build time at build
time we introduce a dialogue markup
language to let developers provide api
definitions natural language response
template as well as a small set of
sample dialogues with annotated system
actions
then our dialog simulator will use this
as inputs to generate a good amount of
dialog variations the simulator
generates dialog variations in two steps
first a general style of flow variations
represent different paths a conversation
can take such as different sequences of
slot values and divergent passes that
arise when a customer changes their mind
in the second step the simulator injects
language variations into dialogue passes
including alternative expressions of the
same user request
finally we use the dialogs generated by
the simulator to train our models
next let's see how you can build a
conversational skill in our platform
i'm going to briefly
work through our platform and show you
how you can build a conversational skill
using our platform
so um this is a very simple toy skill
that i have um which has only one c
dialogue and one apis
so just look at this api definition get
weather on this um what i get whether
api takes one on cd arguments and it
returns a weather information as a
string
so
in the c dialog
you can see like for each
user and system turn you will need to
annotate
annotated
the dialog act for each term
and in this dialog an user is trying to
ask for the information for the weather
and then alexa is requesting for
the argument for city
and
user is informing the city and then over
here you can also label the variable for
this um
for this city and then it will be used
later in the conversation and if you
want to add
entity confirmation you can also
annotate it with
the della act with confirm
and once user affirmed the confirmation
we can actually call the api
with corresponding
variable and
return with um the weather information
so just to give you some example of the
on user ordinance
so this is on user audience that inform
the city so you can
provide several paraphrase
for this template and you can also like
specify the arguments and the type for
this
and similar for the um the system
response
so this is on the confirmed city that it
will be used from the
system and you can also provide several
different um paraphrase
and also the input arguments for this
template
so i already built a skill so that's
just tested
on the console
how is the weather
which city are you asking
in san francisco
[Music]
so our model kind of like support a
simple user behavior um
variation so i can just do it like
actually i mean new york
just to confirm do you want to know the
weather in new york so we can see here
like it can actually
correct the arguments and carry over the
intent
yes
today in new york high is 65 and low is
52 degrees
yes so this is all i have for today um
thank you for joining and for all the
other informations or reference you can
go through our paper thank you
you